tenemos esta expresión que está bastante
complicada porque involucra
multiplicaciones y divisiones de varios
términos y lo que queremos es expresar
el resultado de todas estas operaciones
de una forma sencilla ok ahora aquí
podemos notar que tenemos dos elementos
que están escritos en notación
científica y cuando eso sucede a mí me
gusta convertir el resto de los
elementos anotación científica porque
hace que todo fluya de una forma más
sencilla aunque entonces vamos a empezar
por transformar estos dos números que no
están escritos en forma de notación
científica a anotación científica ok
este no está en forma de notación
científica porque es estrictamente menor
que 1 y para que un número este escrito
connotación científica tiene que haber
un número que en este caso sería
este-oeste que sea mayor o igual que 1
pero estrictamente menor que 10
multiplicando a una potencia de 10
aunque la potencia de 10 si puede ser un
1 por ejemplo el número 9 está escrito
en notación científica porque es 9 por
10 a la 0 que es igual a 9 por 1 que es
igual a 9 pero bueno
el chiste es que esto son dos décimas o
sea que lo podríamos escribir como dos
por una décima cierto lo podremos
escribir como dos por punto 11 entre 10
entonces esto de aquí lo podemos
escribir como 2 por una vez y me en que
es 10 a la menos 1 aunque hay uno entre
10 es 10 a la menos 1 entonces ya
escribimos a punto 2 en notación
científica ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo
con este otro número de aquí tenemos por
aquí 50 mil pero 50.000 se puede
escribir como 5 por 10 mil y 10 mil es
igual a 10 a la 4 entonces esto de aquí
se puede escribir como 5 por 10 a la 4
aunque de hecho podemos contar los ceros
o hay uno dos tres cuatro ceros entonces
ya tenemos cada uno de los elementos que
se están multiplicando escrito
connotación científica así es que
tenemos un bonche de términos multiplica
entonces podemos cambiar el orden en el
que las multiplicamos y eso es justo lo
que vamos a hacer para que todo sea más
sencillo ok entonces vamos a empezar con
este tenemos que esto es igual a 4.6 por
este 2 de aquí por 2 por este 10 a las 6
de aquí por 10 a las 6 por 10 a la menos
1 por 10 al menos 1
y de la misma forma podemos reacomodar
los factores del denominador vamos a
empezar por este 55 por ahora vamos a
tomar este 2.3 2.3
ahora vamos a tomar este 10 a la 4 por
10 a la 4 y finalmente vamos a tomar
este 10 a la menos 2
10 al menos 2 bueno y ahora tenemos que
simplificar este bonche de términos que
tenemos aquí que podemos empezar por
hacer la multiplicación de estos dos
términos
tenemos que esto es igual a haber 4.6
por 2
9.2 cierto bien 9.2
10 a las 6 por 10 a la menos 1 pues
tenemos exactamente la misma base
entonces solo tenemos que sumar los
exponentes
6 + menos 15 así es que por aquí vamos a
poner por 10 a las 5
ahora en el denominador tenemos estos
dos números que se pueden multiplicar 5
por 2 es 10 + 5 por punto 3 que es 1.5
entonces nos queda 10 más 1.5 que es
11.5 y finalmente si multiplicamos estas
dos cosas tenemos 10 a la 4 x 10 a la
menos 2 misma base se suman exponentes y
nos queda 10 a la 4 - 2 que es
10 a las 2 ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es tomar estos dos números y
realizar esta división y la verdad es
que ya nos toca practicar eso de hacer
divisiones con puntos decimales porque
hace un montón que no lo revisemos
entonces vamos a hacerlo al menos 9.2
entre 11.5 a ver cuando tenemos una
división de números que tienen decimales
sabemos que podemos recorrer el punto
decimal la misma cantidad de veces
adentro y afuera del símbolo de división
y si hacemos eso el resultado no es
afectado aunque entonces vamos a mover
el punto decimal de aquí para que y de
aquí para que poner por aquí el punto
decimal también lo tenemos que poner por
aquí de paso voy a poner varios ceros
porque tengo la sensación de que los
vamos a usar y la división de 9.2 entre
11.5 es exactamente igual a la división
de 92 entre 115 entonces vamos a empezar
por dividir 115 no cabe en 92 entonces
vamos a necesitar el primer cero y ahora
si nos preguntamos cuántas veces cabe
115 en 920 y yo digo que cabe como 8
veces entonces 8 por 5 es 40 y llevamos
48 por 184 esos son 12 llevamos 18 por
18 más 19 porque entonces 8 por 115 es
920 que es justo lo que queremos obtener
entonces tenemos residuos cero y podemos
escribir que 9.2 entre 11.5 es igual a
punto 8 ahora nada más nos falta sacar
la división
10 a las 5 entre 10 a las 2 pero eso es
muy fácil porque tenemos la misma base
entonces nada más tenemos que restar los
exponentes entonces nos queda por 10
elevado a la 5 menos 2 y 5 menos 2
estrés y así se ve mucho más simple no
ahora la pregunta es si ya terminamos 1
pues bueno si queremos escribir esto con
notación científica pues todavía no
hemos terminado porque esto de aquí no
es mayor o igual a 1 es menor que 1 y si
queremos que esté en notación científica
tiene que ser mayor o igual a 1 sin
embargo lo podemos arreglar muy
fácilmente punto 8 es igual a 8 décimas
y entonces lo podemos escribir como 8
por una décima
sin embargo una décima es una potencia
de 10 de hecho es exactamente 10 a la
menos 1 así es que esto de aquí lo
podemos escribir
8 por 10 a la menos uno aunque hay días
al menos uno es igual a punto 1 y nos
falta multiplicar por 10 a la 3 por 10 a
la 3 entonces nada más tenemos que
simplificar esta expresión que es igual
a 8 por 10 a la menos 1 por 10 a la 3 es
igual a 10 al menos uno más tres que es
igual a 10 al cuadrado y ahora sí si
simplificamos esta expresión nos queda
esto